veamos la formación de un alcohol usando
un agente reductor empezaremos con boro
hidruro de sodio
si queremos dibujar la estructura de
esto tenemos un boro rodeado de cuatro
hidrógenos lo que le da al boro una
carga formal negativa y por acá tenemos
nuestro camión de sodio los agentes
reductores son como agentes de
transferencia de hidruro vamos a
transferir un híbrido a nuestro aldehído
oa nuestra acetona recordemos que un y
duro es un hidrógeno con dos electrones
libres lo que le da una carga forma
negativa entonces mostremos la
transferencia desde el boro hidruro de
sodio a nuestro carbón y lo recuerden
que el carbón hilo es parcialmente
negativo y parcialmente positivo
este par de electrones atacará a este
carbono empujando estos electrones hacia
el oxígeno
ahora tenemos a nuestro carbono unido a
un hidrógeno y del lado izquierdo
tenemos nuestro oxígeno con tres pares
de electrones libres y una carga formal
negativa por aquí una r y una h sigamos
a los electrones estos electrones en
azul formaron este enlace y este es el
hidrógeno que transferimos el hidrógeno
y este par de electrones usamos boro
hidruro de sodio porque él y bruno por
sí solo no es un buen núcleo filo el
orbital es muy pequeño para interactuar
con este carbono por eso necesitamos un
agente de transferencia como el boro
hidruro de sodio una vez que agregamos
el hidruro podemos protón ar el alcohol
sido una forma seria
en un segundo paso en el que añadimos
una fuente de protones pero otra forma
sería agregar nuestro boro hidruro de
sodio con algún tipo de alcohol como
metano y etanol o incluso agua todo
depende de cómo quieran hacer la
reacción lo que importa es agregar este
hidrógeno y este par de electrones a
este carbono si regresamos un poco
analicemos nuestro aldehído acetona aquí
tenemos un carbono unido con un doble
enlace a este oxígeno y después al
agregar un y bruno el carbono solo queda
unido por un enlace al oxígeno reducimos
el carbón y lo si analizáramos los
estados de oxidación veríamos que este
carbono en rojo fue reducido
los agentes reductores reducen el carbón
y lo para formar un alcohol
veamos un ejemplo en donde usamos boro y
duro de sodio aquí tenemos un acetona y
usaremos boro y duro de sodio en metanol
para nuestro producto final podemos
dibujar nuestro anillo
que no sufre ningún cambio y queremos
añadir un hidrógeno y dos electrones a
nuestro carbono en el carbón y lo vamos
a dibujarlo por aquí
agregamos un hidrógeno y dos electrones
y por acá tendríamos un al cocido pero
como lo proponemos entonces formamos un
alcohol empezamos con un acetona y
terminamos con un alcohol secundario el
carbono unido al h está unido a otros
dos carbonos reducimos una cetona para
formar un alcohol secundario otro agente
reductor es el y duro de litio y
aluminio dibujemos la estructura de eso
tenemos un aluminio
unido a cuatro hidrógenos lo que le da
una carga formal negativa y por acá
tenemos el ión de litio con una carga
formal positiva
este es nuestro agente de transferencia
de hidruro este par de electrones y este
hidrógeno atacarán justo aquí
transfiriéndose al carbón hilo y
empujando estos electrones hacia el
oxígeno este es un mecanismo muy
simplificado pero es más fácil de
entenderlo ahora tenemos nuestro arco
óxido del lado izquierdo
con una carga formal negativa en nuestro
oxígeno del lado derecho hemos agregado
este hidrógeno y estos electrones al
inicio ya teníamos un hidrógeno en
nuestro aldehído que sería este
hidrógeno ahora necesitamos protón ar
nuestro arco óxido así que en el segundo
paso podemos agregar agua un ácido
diluido o algo que nos ayude a protón ar
el alcohol sido entonces toma un protón
dejando estos electrones así formamos
nuestro alcohol como producto lo
dibujaré por aquí
este es nuestro alcohol o h vamos a
contar los carbonos para asegurarnos de
que lo hicimos bien empezamos con este
es el carbono 1 2 3 4 carbonos y
terminamos con 1 2 3 4 carbonos
agregamos un hidruro de este lado
y por acá ya teníamos un hidrógeno en
nuestro aldehído este es nuestro
producto empezamos con un aldehído y al
reducirlo formamos un alcohol primario
porque el carbono al que está unido
nuestro h está unido a otro carbono la
reducción de un aldehído usando hidruro
de litio y aluminio nos da la formación
de un alcohol primario ahora cuando usen
hidruro de litio y aluminio
definitivamente tienen que hacer la
reacción en dos pasos les diré por qué
muchas veces si mezclamos hidruro de
litio y aluminio con agua pueden
reaccionar violentamente incluso puede
ser peligroso aquí tenemos la carga
formal negativa de nuestro aluminio si
mezclamos todo esto al mismo tiempo lo
que ocurrirá
a una transferencia de hidruro esto
tomara un protón del agua y se formará
hidrógeno gaseoso h2 que puede llegar a
ser muy peligroso
el boro hidruro de sodio no es tan
reactivo como el hidruro de litio y
aluminio por eso se puede usar en un
alcohol pero cuando usen hidruro de
litio y aluminio deben asegurarse de que
todo esté completamente seco ahora
hablemos un poco más sobre la diferencia
de reactividad entre el hidruro de litio
y aluminio y el boro hidruro de sodio en
el caso del boro hidruro de sodio nos
interesa el enlace entre el boro y este
hidrógeno y para el hidruro de litio y
aluminio nos interesa el aluminio unido
a este hidrógeno en cuanto a las
diferencias de electro negatividad
el boro tiene un valor de
aproximadamente 2
y aluminio de aproximadamente 1.5
recuerden que hablamos sobre transferir
estos electrones así que el boro es más
electro negativo que el aluminio eso
significa que quiere quedarse más con
los electrones mientras que para el
aluminio le resulta fácil dejarlos ir
por eso el aluminio es más reactivo
porque está dispuesto a transferir el
hidruro ya sea a una molécula de agua o
a un carbón hilo sin embargo como el
duro de litio y aluminio es más reactivo
reducirá más grupos funcionales que el
boro hidruro de sodio veamos lo que
tenemos aquí empezaremos con este
compuesto primero hagamos la reducción
con boro hidruro de sodio
el boro hidruro de sodio reaccionará con
nuestro aldehído y no será tan fuerte
para poder reducir al
así que solo reaccionará con esta parte
de la molécula dibujemos el producto
final para este caso aquí tenemos
nuestro anillo
y cómo reducimos el aldehído entonces
nos queda o h empezamos con un hidrógeno
unido a este carbono y ahora tenemos dos
déjenme resaltar los uno de estos ya
estaba en nuestra molécula y después
agregamos uno por transferencia digamos
que fue este hidrógeno
reducimos el aldehído para formar un
alcohol y la parte esther permanece
igual vamos a dibujarla
entonces el boro hidruro de sodio es
selectivo con el aldehído no es tan
fuerte para reducir al este en cambio el
hidruro de litio y aluminio reducir a
ambos grupos funcionales dibujemos el
producto aquí tenemos nuestro anillo
y nuevamente reducimos nuestro aldehído
a un alcohol
digamos que este es el hidrógeno que ya
teníamos y este es el hidrógeno y el par
de electrones que transferimos
ahora también reducimos al este así que
tenemos un o h
y dos hidrógenos que agregamos en esta
reducción vamos a resaltar los
transferimos este hidrógeno y estos
electrones este hidrógeno y estos
electrones en este caso reducimos y
agregamos dos y duros y claro no olviden
que en el segundo paso agregamos una
fuente de protones en condiciones
normales el boro hidruro de sodio
reducirá aldehídos y cetonas mientras
que el duro de litio y aluminio al ser
más reactivo reducirá aldehídos cetonas
ésteres y ácidos carboxílicos hablaremos
más sobre esto en los siguientes vídeos